imagine you're a chaperon on your
18-year-old daughter's you know school
trip it's an
overnight and yet you find out during
the trip that she's being forced to
share a bed with a biological male yeah
that happened Serena Wales doesn't have
to imagine the scenario it did happen to
her and her family she says her daughter
called her in a panic from the bathroom
of the hotel saying that she didn't want
to share a bed with a biological boy no
matter how much they got along Serena
joins me now exclusively along with her
husband Joe Wales and their attorney
Tyson langhoffer from the alliance
defending Freedom Serena it's stunning
that you were on this trip as a chaperon
thank God you were there during the
summer but then in another room so you
were in the other room what happened
when you asked uh for your 11-year-old
daughter to move
rooms well thank you Laura for having us
on and sharing our story um as you said
we were my 11-year-old daughter and
myself were on a cross country trip to
Philly in DC and on the first night of
the trip our daughter discovered that
she was unknowingly assigned to share a
bed with a boy who identifies as a girl
and I just want to point out that we
love our principal we love our school we
love our teachers but what we don't love
is this District policy that um doesn't
allow all students to feel comfortable
and secure and protected and it doesn't
allow all parents to protect their
children and guide them the best way
they see fit and that's what we felt we
were lacking on this trip
well Joe your wife is a lot nicer than I
would be in this circumstance I mean I I
to me it's not about whether someone's
nice or not you know most people are
nice most people are nice people your
daughter is going to be in a bed with a
boy M and this is when your wife is on
the trip these facts are so mind-blowing
to me I can't even believe them but Joe
at this point you know did you consider
pulling your daughter out of the trip
and just saying we're we're out of here
I mean you weren't there but but at that
point I would have hit the road and
probably moved schools but that's just
me uh yeah honestly that was my first
reaction and as we sat and we talked
about it we didn't want to take the trip
away from our daughter she didn't do
anything wrong we didn't do anything
wrong so we didn't want to take the trip
from her she looked forward to the trip
for quite some time so we wanted to make
sure she was able to enjoy her trip well
Tyson I understand that you're the
attorney for lines defending Freedom you
do great work by the way and these
parents are trying to balance you know
having a normal experience for their
daughter and this District polic that
requires treating everybody and you know
everyone's equal no one's different what
do you do well you do what they did
which is call lines defending freedom
and and and stand up for their daughter
and what they and so what we're asking
the school to do is to tell parents what
the policy is one and two to allow the
parents to opt their children out if
they're you know if they find out that
their their daughter their 11-year-old
daughter is going to be sleeping in the
same bed with a boy uh that's wrong that
it's wrong have to opt I mean it seems
like why do you have to opt out this
should not even be a a question at all
it absolutely should not be a question I
agree with that but if the school is
going to have this policy they
absolutely should not be able to hide
this information from parents they're
hiding it and Serena what happened when
you asked to have your daughter move
rooms uh briefly what
happened well she actually when we were
able to finally do it we she and I were
not able to discuss what happened with
anybody else on the trip we were told to
hide it because to protect all of the
students that were on the
trip what wait a second you're trying to
control your freedom of expression as a
as a your daughter's
expression and your concern
Joe your thoughts here I guess you can't
speak about it this is you know this is
uh you know the CCP land you can't you
can't you can't speak the truths
anymore right right well we were you
know like you you mentioned I I wasn't
on the trip I I was finding out I was
here at home with my other two children
and uh and our daughter called us and or
called me and told me what was going on
I called Serena asked you know is this
really what's happening and she
confirmed the story and um from there we
you know we started trying to figure out
how we were going to address this issue
and um we do feel like it's a story that
needs to be told we think all kids
deserve respect and privacy but it needs
to be applied equally uh to to all
children and this policy the way it is
right now is is very
one-sided w uh all of you lines
defending Freedom fantastic work thank
you for doing what you're doing Joe
Serena thank you for telling your story
that's it for us tonight hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else